d'autres sollicitations après une
carrière dans la ligue nationale style
déjà opté enfin son diplôme d'études
secondaires après vingt deux ans c'est
assez difficile de retourner surtout en
français j'ai trouvé ça j'adorerais ça
sérieusement comme j'ai dit je vais y
ait des tripes sur les défis un défi
lancé par son ami
la légende des arts martiaux georges st
pierre qui l'a relevé sans patins en
battant grâce à l'application challenge
ue avec charles djou tu peux le faire
sur mon cellulaire une plateforme
d'enseignement interactive créée au
québec et les vidéos qui expliquent
ensuite des exercices interactifs et
c'est à travers ce si on a des questions
l'on peut appeler un professeur et
s'emparait des géré par les commissions
scolaires les cours offerts à distance
respecte les exigences du ministère de
l'éducation
c'est pas des diplômes à rabais qui sont
décernés bien que ce ne soit que la
première coureurs des diplômés le taux
de réussite aux examens du ministère de
ses élèves et de 80% un exercice que
steve bégin et comparé aux éliminatoires
avant l'examen
j'étudiais du matin au soir j'étais
tellement stressée tellement nerveuse
j'avais tellement hâte d'aller un peu un
match des séries
mais faut-il craindre l'effet pervers
d'une telle initiative
je crois pas comme je le dis je crois
pas que ça une louve a créé des
décrocheurs je pense plutôt que vous
créez des raccrocheurs des gens qui
travaillent à temps plein à temps
partiel qui ont des enfants que jean
les états côtiers même si steve bégin
n'a pas eu besoin de ce diplôme pour
réussir dans la vie
l'ancien joueur des canadiens souhaité
donner l'exemple à d'autres jeunes
québécois mais surtout à ses deux filles
ils savent que c'est important
les études et
que moi je suis là pour les supporter
que dorénavant je peux être un exemple
pourrait ici jacques andré charbonneau
radio-canada mourir